j'ai été censuré à sciences po paris des
cours sur les approche évolutive du
comportement social ont été lancées 12
jours avant le début de semestre et
c'est là la suite d'une demande
explicite faites par la direction du
programme d'études sur le champ des
sciences po paris leonardo orlando est
docteur en sciences politiques il devait
enseigner un cours intitulé biologie
évolution et genre sur le campus de
sciences po de reims mais une enquête de
l'express a révélé que son cours ancré
dans la théorie de l'évolution de
charles darwin avait été annulée sans
justification je suis allé voir
médiatement la direction j'étais surpris
de l'apathie de la direction face à
cette demande explicite des censures
contraires à toutes les valeurs de
sciences po paris les cours qui ont été
censurés porté sur ce qu on dise
approche évolutive du comportement
social c'est-à-dire une des théories
scientifiques les plus importantes
celles de l'évolution proposée par
charles darwin elle s'applique aux
comportements sociaux dans les cas de
l'un des cours qui fait censurer celui
de paix dit ça sur les questions du
champ des différences physiologiques
entre les hommes et les femmes
différents comportements sont ni
expliquer à la lumière de la théorie de
l'évolution dans les messages qu'on
allait l'animal qui n'avait reçu départ
de la direction c'est indiqué qu est-ce
qu on ne correspondait pas aux critères
scientifiques de l'institution sis est
assez curieux parce que les sauteurs que
les étudiants à les lire qui se les
découvrir dans nos cours ce sont en fait
des chercheurs le plus important dans
ces disciplines et harvard yale des
prisons etc ce sont des choses de base
par rapport à la thur évolutive à la
virologie à la chine éthiques je n'ai eu
aucun contact malheureusement avec la
direction j'ai fais partie de
l'institution je vais passer presque une
décennie du mali à sciences po ce qui
s'est passé à sciences po paris ce n'est
pas un cas isolé ce 6e place dans cinq
contextes dans lesquels darwin et la
théorie des révolutions c'est à vous
dans les départements de sciences
sociales la plupart des enseignements
aujourd'hui ses bases dans ce qui est
appelé les constructions nisme social
l'idée que les instruments ce sont des
table rase passionné par la
socialisation et qui sont malléables à
bord c'est tout simplement faux à la
lumière de ce qui nous a appris la
biologie la primatologie l'anthropologie
physique les neurosciences les sciences
cognitives à sciences po paris
aujourd'hui il y à des chats 80 cours
confirmé sur les questions de jean pour
la rentrée prochaine au camp d'essai 80
cookies disponible en ligne vous pouvez
aller les voir ni comporte une dimension
biologique bien au contraire c'est 80
courts sont à l'opposition un flagrant
déni de ce qui a été ta vie par la
biologie par l'évolution est partout les
sciences du cerveau et des sciences de
la nature en général la situation dans
les universités françaises aujourd'hui
et se rapproche de ce qu'il se passe des
chats aux états unis par rapport à la
halle affaire de censure de darwin en
sciences po il ya certains des plus
grands intellectuels publics tels que
steven pinker de l'université de rabat
ou nicholas christakis des nuances et
enyele qui ont exprimé publiquement leur
désarroi et scandalisée de ce qu'il
s'est passé je n'utilise pas non plus
les chars les mots censure parce que
c'est qu'elle est en train de vivre dans
les départements de sciences sociales
c'est vraiment une situation qui est
déjà en 2005 en philosophe les mac intel
il avait appelé un nouvel âge des
ténèbres dernier département de sciences
sociales et nos jours les étudiants sont
formés surtout à ce qui est appelé par
un philosophe michael shermer les
créationnismes cognitique ni les
millions d'années d'évolution derrière
nous qui ont façonné notre cerveau et
c'est différent de ce qu'on apprend dans
le département sciences sociales